[Musique]
le but c'est de construire une équipe de
rêve mais l'équipe de rêve c'est très
difficile de la voir en gros des
managers vers la fois joueur est à la
fois président du club
c'est ça qui donne l'envi de joie fut de
champion et pour pour avoir ces joueurs
de rêve faut de l'argent
[Musique]
on a quasiment à domicile vous imaginez
c'est tellement simple de pays tue on se
rend même pas compte en espace d'un
petit clic on dépense de l'argent sans
se rendre compte
[Musique]
et point qu'il faille tu peux acheter
autant que tu veux t'en pas de l'argent
dans ta carte bleue c'est payet sport
qui m'a dit wright au début j'ai
commencé 20 euros et qu'il prouvera par
semaine c'est rien 40 euros par semaine
fera au fur et à mesure je monte je
monte je monte et malgré ça et parfois
je m'étais tellement d'argent je
n'arrivais même pas à avoir de bons
joueurs j'ai paquet près de 600 au 2
septembre en même pas trois semaines on
va dire trois semaines trois à quatre
semaines
je vois que j'ai paquet c'est manolas
mais c'est qu'ils malo la csla fallait
que je passe des recherches pour savoir
si kim alors la stib et la gym et donc
c'est trop c'est trop
[Musique]
je vous donne un exemple j'avais rage
fort cash for je commence la saison je
te claque déchets pas combien de buts
avec leur foi et je me retrouve un mois
même pas moi que trois semaines après
rochefort je le reconnais plus la farine
il s'est même qu'ils ferment pas si
c'est même plus frappé qu'est ce que je
fais sur frustré je suis énervé du coup
je remets un coup de carte bleue et
c'est de là à 20 la diction dj t il
il te force à acheter en fait des
moments je me rendais pas coupe moi je
joue et je me dis j'ai mis de l'argent
mon argent je rentabilise et du coup ma
vie familiale jamais tapé deux côtés
tellement j'étais j'étais accro je me
rendais pas compte j'étais il fallait ce
jeu il fallait que je joue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]
c'est un contexte qui des ans soit de
jeux vidéo qui en soi est déjà à
potentiel addictif ça veut pas dire que
tout le monde même pas du tout que tu
monteras dépendants mais qui a un
potentiel
donc effectivement le hasard joue un
rôle même si simplement l'achat et
l'obtention de quelque chose qui va
déclencher une émotion forte
honnêtement je pense qu'il ya vraiment
aussi cette grande partie 2 en fait oui
d'excitation du moment en fait là dans
ce moment là potentiellement il va y
avoir un big one donc je vais peut-être
tomber exactement sur ce que je
cherchais je sais pas parce que c'est le
hasard
mais c'est peut-être exactement ce que
je voulais et donc cet espoir ce moment
d'excitation en fait peut-être que c'est
simplement ça déjà les faits restent
recherchées en fait chez certaines
personnes qu'on développe une tolérance
on a tendance à au bout d'un moment
investir plus donc par exemple dans le
jeu de hasard et d'argent ou dans les
substances avec les addictions avec
substance en fait il faut augmenter la
12 pour avoir le même effet
toi ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
on
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
non
oh
à
moi mon compte ainsi plus de vente de
packs jeu + 2 - 2 bat ici tout
simplement et je veux plus des ados des
adultes us céder tout âge à miser de
l'argent dans le virtuel
on achète le jeu déjà on fait déjà assez